hallo mein name ist mein name ist
herzlich willkommen hier heute zu einem
neuen video
ich hab das ja auch schon bei rio damals
gemacht und jetzt versuche ich auch und
zwar versuche ich einen weltrekord
aufzustellen ihr seht schon wir sind
hier schon im slattery allerdings menüs
finals verdienen das ist tatsächlich
sehr wenig einnahme ist weltrekord mache
ich klicke einfach mal auf play again
und ihr seht schon jo ich kann jetzt
hier rumfahren alle dies eigentlich als
genau das soll nicht erkenne ich erklärt
euch einfach mal ganz kurz und zwar geht
es darum dass ich diese kleine schlange
hier bin und die anderen kleinen teile
hiervon aufsammeln muss und ich bin
gerade zwischen zwei sehr riesigen
schlangen tatsächlich die muss all
diesen kleinen scheißer auffressen und
darf nicht in andere schlange rhein
fahren weil dann bin ich tot und das
sicher nicht der titel dass ich tot bin
sind lässt sich in weltrekord machen
ich habe schon einige videos auf youtube
gesehen wenn man slattery weltrekord 1
gibt ist dem schock in bonn mit
ich habe schon also eingegeben
weltrekord bleibt so ich habe übrigens
die linke maustaste gedrückt halten und
dann mache ich kurz um tempo schub ich
möchte verloren im spiel und in diesen
videos die ich dann gesehen habt die
halt irgendwie silverio weltrekord world
record hießen oder so waren die alle so
eine scheiße maniche war ich war echt
schon groß für meine verhältnisse degas
das ist halt gerade das krasse man kann
nämlich hier extrem schnell wieder
nach oben kommen sage ich mal vario ist
es ja so bekommt nur nach oben indem man
die anderen kleinen teile ist und man
selber schon sehr klein ist und dann
einen großen beispielsweise der steuern
geht das nur über diese kleine teile die
man da halt irgendwie was ist das was da
hab ich das habe ich mich schon gefragt
was das ding ist das vielleicht dass ich
unendlich von dem geschwindigkeit steht
hier fressen kann alter ich weiß was
dieser geschwindigkeit schritt macht ich
habe jetzt verstanden wenn man diese
geschwindigkeit aktiviert dann
allerdings der die eigenen sachen
wirklich wird kleiner und auch die
sachen hier liegen lassen ich blöd corp
ist ja auch komplett egal jedenfalls war
bei den ganzen weltrekord videos hat
immer ultra riesiges tor des chors am
start das heißt die waren teilweise so
fett locker so fett oder so fett aber
wir probieren einfach unser bestes und
das ist der versuch vom letzten
weltrekord aufzustellen
ich werde es aber nicht schaffen das
kann ich denke ich schon mal versprechen
benzin ist es jetzt diese riesige
schlachten ein fucking gott wieso ist
denn diese ultra riesig hier würde ich
gerade tatsächlich sehr gerne einfach
mal auf altherr schweder wieso ist denn
die so gross immer nicht am respekt vor
dir damit das schippern großen kabasi
verteilt mit leichten abgaben an ich
denke die ganze zeit eine marge von
dieser riesigen schlange man heulen und
die da vorne kann ich auch nicht töten
und da der frist schon wieder die ganzen
kleinen sachen oh mein gott nein nein du
schütze mein gott ok ganzen übels alex
gefressen
schnell noch den darm an jeder verliert
mein gott war das gratin das ist nichts
für mich ich gehe mal ein bisschen
wieder nach außerhalb ihr blöd nur wenn
man hier an diesem turbo aktivieren oder
die linke maustaste gedrückt hält dann
ist das so wie mit seinem automatik
ein wagen man drückt drauf und dann hört
ganz früh aber dann geht's los ein
bisschen weiter es noch runter schaltet
so ist es nämlich auch also der jetzt
nicht instant direkt im links guckt so
das ist ein bisschen blöd ich bin
neunter ich bin mir nicht sicher ob ich
das jetzt da okay ich bin gerade zehnter
aber ich bin mir nicht sicher ob ich das
bin oder irgendwie anders weil ich bin
ja eigentlich auch schon unglaublich wie
sich gerade oder alles kann mich
zumindest nicht habt ihr diesen schritt
hier luca ja genau das ja alles fressen
und jetzt aber nein nein
war noch nie so gut im spiel freunde das
war für mich persönlich auf jeden fall
ein rekorden weltrekord noch nicht aber
das schaffe ich beim nächsten mal
das war es mit diesem video
ich habe es versucht ich war sehr gut
dabei ich war den top ten aber ich war
tatsächlich nicht
ich glaube es war kein weltrekord wenn
euch severin schmid bleibt trotzdem
gefällt und die das vielleicht einmal
auf einem kanal sehen wollt vielleicht
mit weiß nicht was irgendwie ob ich dann
mal was anderes probieren die challenge
oder so blabla dann zeigt sie mit einer
bewertung wir sehen uns morgen bei kein
plan was morgen kommt vielleicht kommt
noch gar nichts